How long can mycotoxins stay in your system?
Well, remember mycotoxins are toxins from mold. They're not the mold itself.
So it's not a living organism and it probably has those those poisons have probably have a half life of 15 million years
So they can stay in your system as long as you don't detoxify them. Remember any toxins that you can measure in your system are
Things that you're you know, you are trying to get rid of. So when you do a urine test, you're you're getting rid of those things
That means you have them in you to get rid of them. Your body is constantly detox, trying to detoxify. If you're not detoxifying
You're going to be dead at a very short period of time. You have to be able to detoxify
so
The true well, then why do I have these I'm not detoxifying. Well, you have them because you were either exposed to more than you could detoxify at any given time or
You're just detoxifying more slowly. You are detoxifying. So there's nobody that's not detoxifying
Remember the level of toxicity in your system is equal to the level of exposure of said toxins minus your ability to get rid of them. So there's times that we're hyper exposed to things.
And there's times that our liver is compromised and we're just not able to get rid of
A normal amount, but because none of these things are normal. So, but maybe the amount that we couldn't gotten rid of last week, our stress level is up to our liver is compromised. Remember, stress is going to affect our liver's ability to detoxify because stress increases your sympathetic nervous system, and it's going to decrease your liver detoxification function. Remember
The neurology of liver detoxification is tied to the parasympathetic nervous system. So one other thing you can think of to help detoxify, you know, just had a chat with somebody today about toxins in their system, and they are
On into a rejection drug so they can't take a lot of key laders because they could be key laded out the medication that they're taking. So they have to be careful with that. So then you can
So then you have to get a little bit more creative, which all of us should be doing one of the ways that you can help with liver detoxification pathways without changing body chemistry
By adding a supplement or something is to support the parasympathetic system. So there is a blog post. If you go back to our website, I actually have this video on multiple places on our member site too. I just can't remember off the top of my head. But if you go back to our website, you just do the search bar and you search or parasympathetic, you will you will see that there is
blog post in a video on how to stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system. And on that blog post, there's a downloadable PDF where you can there's a bunch of different exercises. You can do functional neurology exercises. You can do to help stimulate your parasympathetics. There's also a PDF on some different functional neurology exercise. You can do to calm the sympathetic. So watch the video that will help explain that
how to stimulate your sympathetic how to stimulate your parasympathetics and call me your sympathetic and that will go a long way with helping stimulated immune response, helping to stimulate detoxification pathways, help to call your heart very good for your heart, very good for your brain, decrease anxiety, et cetera, et cetera.
So we live in a sympathetic driven world. You have a scary diagnosis. It's going to stimulate your sympathetic nervous system. It's going to cause anxiety. It's going to cause depression. You want to stimulate your parasympathetics as much as possible.
So go to that post. You'll get a lot of little hints. And if you download that that PDF and see some seemingly silly things you could do that will stimulate the neurology. So it's all about stimulating that neurologic path of the vagal nerve, cranial nerve 10. And then call me the part of the brain called the mess and cephalon, which is responsible for stimulating your sympathetic. So there's a need for sympathetic tone.
You want a balance of this when you know a lion jumps out in front of you and you have to fight that lion or run away. You need a healthy sympathetic nervous system.
But we live in a world where there's constantly lions were constantly putting out fires were constantly running away from issues in our mind. So even anything that is a perceived lion in our life is going to stimulate our sympathetic.
So we have to be actively trying to stimulate the parasympathetic nervous system.
Long answer to how long can Michael toxins stay in our system. But the honest answer is they'll stay in our system until we get rid of them.
Any toxins that you're exposed to that you absorb that circulate into your bloodstream are going to stay in you until you get rid of them.
Again, your level of toxicity at any given moment is equal to the level of exposure minus your ability to get rid of them.
So if you show high that talks detect tester you show high on glyphosate tester you show high on Michael toxic test.
You're just not getting rid of these things. So you need to aid your body as best you can because these things get inside cells and they cause.
All sorts of problems cancer is one of them but it gets inside your brain it causes inflammation it causes microglial priming it leads to Alzheimer's early dementia it leads to Parkinson's it leads to all sorts of problems.
So make sure that you stay focused on your purposes to detoxify.